oi oi eu posso te fazer uma pergunta é
sim eu sei que essa já é uma pergunta
mas eu tenho certeza que você respondeu
ela mesmo sem querer na sua cabeça nesse
caso quer dizer que você está preparado
para as minhas próximas perguntas Então
vou te falar como que a gente vai
conseguir daqui a diante toda vez que eu
te fazer uma pergunta eu vou te dar 5
segundos para você pensar nem tal mente
na resposta para ela então vamos lá da
primeira pergunta
Oi como que você está se sentindo hoje
e acabou o tempo perfeito fácil sobre
não conseguiu então a gente vai para
perguntar dois mas agora você presta
atenção porque ela tem uma pegadinha a
pergunta número 2 ela vai ser igual a
pergunta número um mas dessa vez quando
você for responder ela olha na sua
cabeça você não pode usar nenhuma
palavra Então vamos lá como que você
está se sentindo hoje
e acabou o tempo e aí eu imagino que
deve ter sido mais difícil agora mas
porque será que ficou tão difícil de
repente segura aí um pouco a pergunta
porque eu tenho a terceira pergunta para
você a gente vai pensar junto então
vamos lá
se por acaso quando você pensou lá na
minha primeira pergunta Quem te deu a
resposta para ela foi uma voz dentro da
sua cabeça se foi você fica se
preocupado porque você é um ser humano
normal não tem nada de errado com você e
essa voz e falou com você na sua cabeça
é a sua voz interna e ela é responsável
por uma coisa que a gente chama de
discurso interno agora essa coisa do
discurso interno ela ainda é uma área
com muitas perguntas em aberto dentro da
psicologia e da Neurologia mas tem
algumas coisas sobre elas que a gente já
sabe por exemplo que o nosso discurso
interno ele tá ligado as várias
atividades mentais que a gente realiza
todos os dias e também que a gente tem a
tendência externalizar esse discurso
interno quanto mais difícil é atividade
que a gente realiza por exemplo quantas
vezes você não tava lendo dentro da sua
cabeça um mesmo parágrafo e não tava
entendendo nada e aí você teve aqui
dizeres parágrafo em voz alta e são as
a realização e a última coisa que eu
acho mais interessante é que o nosso
discurso interno ele tá ligado a nossa
capacidade de entender a nós mesmos de
acordo com professor chamado Charles sem
Hall que ele é um pesquisador do
discurso interno ele acredita que o
nosso discurso interno ele ajuda a
coordenar todas as nossas memórias
nossos pensamentos e os nossas
experiências colocar tudo isso junto
para que a gente possa olhar para essas
coisas analisá-las e tirar conclusões a
respeito disso E como você pode notar
com as minhas duas primeiras perguntas
até certo. O nosso discurso interno ele
é dependente da linguagem das palavras
sente o nosso dia a dia e essa é uma
ideia bastante interessante porque se as
palavras são essa ferramenta que o nosso
reforço interno utiliza para que a gente
tem esses tipos de pensamentos
analíticos então será que quanto mais
palavras eu tiver
é mais capacidade eu tenho de enxergar o
meu mundo e pensar nele de diferentes
maneiras Será que a nossa linguagem é
capaz de moldar a forma como a gente
pensa
não existe alguns estudos que parecem
suportar essa ideia
e a professora largura diz que é uma
pesquisadora da Universidade da
Califórnia em uma coisa que ela estuda é
a forma como diferentes culturas com
diferentes duas nativas pensam a
respeito do tempo e por que que eu tempo
o tempo porque ele é um elemento
abstrato ele não é uma coisa concreta
que nem essa poltrona por exemplo ele é
uma coisa que existe no nossa cabeça e
por isso que é interessante a gente vê
como outras culturas enxergam esse
elemento Mas voltando para os estudos
hoje eu perceber o que a gente tem uma
maneira muito peculiar de sempre arrumar
as nossas linhas temporais começando com
o passado a esquerda e futura direita
todas as nossas representações acabam
sempre desse jeito até aqueles programas
de antes e depois de transformação
também são assim a gente se colocava o
antes o passado a esquerda e o depois o
futuro à direita a gente até estranhar
se de repente alguém mudasse mas só que
eu não tinha
é isso não se repete em todas as
culturas se você falasse hebraico ou
árabe você provavelmente colocaria sua
linha do tempo ao contrário o seu
passado estaria direita e o seu futuro
estaria esquerdo se você falasse chinês
ou japonês talvez você nem colocasse na
horizontal colocassem na vertical Como
passado em cima e futuro em baixo mas
porque será que tem tantas diferenças
desse jeito Isso está ligado a nossa
linguagem escrita porque no português a
gente faz exatamente Sim a gente começa
as nossas frases a esquerda termina a
direita em hebraico Elas começam direita
e terminam a esquerda e no japonês ou
chinês Você tem sempre a possibilidade
de começar em cima e terminar em baixo
esse é só um exemplo de como a nossa
linguagem e a nossa convenção parecem
estar atrelada de alguma forma e nesse
caso elas influenciam a forma como a
gente enxerga nossa realidade ou uma
pequena parte dela o tempo
e o outro experimento interessante
também feito pela professora boroditsky
é um que envolve cores no Russo a gente
tem duas palavras diferentes essas duas
tonalidades que nós em português
chamaríamos de azul a gente tem as
tonalidades de azul mais escuro que a
gente chama de Sim e as tonalidades de
azul mais claros chamado de bolo Boy ou
seja nessa língua a gente codifica esta
mesma realidade o azul usando duas
categorias dois conceitos diferentes eo
mais interessante é que como testados os
outros são mais rápidos todo
diferenciado tons de cores e caem em
categorias linguísticas diferentes O que
quer dizer que para eles é mais fácil
dizer que essas duas tonalidades de
cores são diferentes do que essas duas
finalidades coisas são diferentes
em qual a gente analisa o cérebro dessas
pessoas o que é interessante também é
que toda vez que a gente mostra a
realidade né a situação em que existem
as categorias linguísticas diferentes o
cérebro dessas pessoas me mostra uma
atividade mais pronunciada é quase como
um sinal que o cérebro da avisando que
amigo é para você prestar atenção aqui
por favor porque tem alguma coisa
diferente por outro lado e línguas como
português em inglês que não fazem essa
categorização linguística para gente é
tudo azul um tanto a diferença na
velocidade diferenciação quanto o sinal
cerebral simplesmente não existem tudo
isso porque em diferentes línguas a
gente
e decodifica a mesma realidade
utilizando conceitos diferentes e esses
conceitos são os coisas que treinam
nosso cérebro para ter certeza que a
gente vai diferenciar alguma coisa que
existe naquela realidade a maior
conclusão que a gente pode tirar a
partir desses estudos é exatamente a
resposta para pergunta que eu tinha
feito lá atrás Será que a linguagem pode
afetar a forma como a gente pensa é a
resposta para isso é sim até
determinado. Ela pode Inclusive essa é
uma faca de dois gumes por que na mesma
forma que a interpretação da realidade
cria necessidade dos conceitos os
conceitos nos amigos não a interpretar a
realidade
bom pensando uma analogia é como se
esses conceitos fossem lentes que a
gente pode usar e através delas olhar o
mundo e dessa forma enxergar a nossa
realidade através de uma perspectiva
diferente a perspectiva desse conceito e
quanto mais conceitos a gente tiver a
mais lente dessas a gente tem acessos
Isso é ótimo Porque quanto mais maneiras
a gente tiver de olhar para o número
mais chances a gente tem que tirar boas
conclusões a respeito dele e ter mais
idéias e como mudá-lo para melhor
é perfeito Então agora que a gente sabe
que tudo isso a pergunta que vale um
milhão de dólares é como que a gente
consegue mais conceitos para ter acesso
a mais dessas lentes de ver o mundo
e talvez meu dicionário bom se você
pensou mais ou menos por aí não tá muito
longe também da Verdade mas ainda não é
essa resposta porque nós seres humanos a
gente não aprende simplesmente vem de
uma palavra aleatória por aí Nós seres
humanos a gente aprende através de
experiência a nossa experiência ou a
experiência dos outros passadas pra
gente através da linguagem Nós seres
humanos a gente aprende através de
histórias e agora a gente chegou na
minha parte favorita dessa conversa
a todos nós nascemos e crescemos
rodeados de histórias a história dos
nossos pais se a história dos nossos
amigos a história do nosso país das
nossas crenças
em todas elas nos ensinaram os conceitos
que a gente entende como tem mal certo e
errado e inevitavelmente elas
influenciaram a nossa forma de ver o
mundo por exemplo o meu pai era um ótimo
contador de histórias e como eu era
pequeno ele sempre me contava a história
de como ele tinha saído de uma casa em
que as vezes ele passava fome e depois
de trabalhar muito chegou num ponto em
que ele tinha inclusive como ajudar
financeiramente outras pessoas da
família dele e essa história me ensinou
muito mais os conceitos de dedicação
trabalho duro porque se eu tivesse
simplesmente linda essas palavras no
dicionário Mas o que eu percebi aos
poucos é que o meu pai ele era apenas um
homem com uma única vida e o número
limitado de história você me contar e
essa altura já gostava muito de
histórias Então eu fui atrás de
encontrar essas histórias em outros
lugares eu já encontrei foi nos Livros
mas especificamente nos livros de ficção
a cada vez eu li um livro a seguinte
frase
não é estranho não é amar um livro
quando as palavras nas páginas se tornam
tão preciosa se parecem fazer parte da
sua própria história porque elas são bom
a autora desse livro era em ordem
externa provém que eu tava pensando uma
coisa muito mais poética na hora que ela
escreveu essa frase Mas o que eu fiquei
pensando é o com verdade não poderia ser
essa frase quero escrever o ponto para
você saber existem alguns estudos
neurológicos que dizem que os mesmos
pontos que ficam ativos no cérebro de
uma pessoa que está lendo sobre um ação
são exatamente os mesmos pontos que
ativam caso tivesse executando aquelas
são embora em menor proporção isso quer
dizer que quando você ler um livro e
você não tá só olhando para a história a
partir da perspectiva daquele personagem
mas até certo. Você tá assim dizendo
aquela história e como era em ordem você
falou
e ela vai se tornando parte da sua
própria história e os conceitos que você
aprendeu com ela vão se tornando mais um
conselho que não sou biblioteca e mais
uma lente que você pode usar para
enxergar o seu novo
e eu com uma amante de história de longa
data eu poderia passar muito tempo
falando quantas conceitos eu já aprendi
nas várias histórias que eu já li na
minha vida mas existem alguns conceitos
em algumas histórias que ficaram lá em
gravadas e são conceitos que eu faço
questão de utilizar todos os dias para
ver a minha atividade e eles são o
conceito de coragem que aprendi com a
Lyra belacqua da Bússola de Ouro quando
eu tinha 13 anos de idade
e o conceito de lealdade que eu aprendi
com Percy Jackson E esse foi um dos
livros que me iniciou na minha vida de
leitura também como uma pessoa que lê
mangás que me falou que e foi tebet me
ensinaram um dos conceitos mais
complexos e mais transformadores que eu
aprendi com a leitura ou conceito de
gentileza o conceito de fome e o spand
com o nome do vento não só porque nesse
livro o personagem e limita realmente
passa fome por alguns momentos Mas mesmo
depois de ter comida na mesa eu sinto
como se ele tivesse fome de muitas
outras coisas
Ah e por fim com estar lesse ou um lar
sem estrelas darem ordens que tem que eu
já mencionei aqui Esse livro me ensinou
o conceito de histórias as diferentes
formas que elas podem tomar e como no
fundo nós somos todos os criadores de
histórias e amantes de histórias de um
jeito ou de outro Toda vez que você lê
um livro um novo conceito vai ser
adicionado na sua biblioteca de
conceitos e uma nova lente pela qual
enxergar o mundo vai estar disponível
para você utilizar e nessa hora aquela
voz dentro da sua cabeça seu discurso
interno vai ser utilizado esses
conceitos para você analisar o mundo e
poder tirar ótimas são funções que que é
isso a partir dele
e mais se apesar de tudo que eu te falei
aqui hoje ainda pegar um e nas mãos e lê
ainda parece uma atividade muito difícil
eu tenho certeza que você ainda só não
encontrou a história certa para você e
para te ajudar encontrar a história
certa hoje existem em todas as redes
sociais mais populares uma multidão de
pessoas apaixonadas por Leitura entre
elas eu que estão lá dispostas ela te
pegar pela mão e te ajudar encontrar nas
mesmas páginas de livros o mesmo
encantamento que a gente encontrou não
sei você a gente leu
e como a ele engorda entende-se que está
lê-se
a mim todas as histórias falam com todos
os vídeos mas todos os ouvintes podem
encontrar uma que fale com eles alguma
hora em algum lugar sim sim